Ray Allen two-time NBA champ and got a
new book from the outside my journey
through life and the game I love
available now online and Weber books are
sold
ray good morning thanks for joining us
20th anniversary of he got game and
Denzel Washington was on the show
recently and I asked him this was I
think a couple of months ago this is
what Denzel had to say about a sequel
and I said sequel to he got game and he
said if you're in he's in no right he
said he would work on it but he said he
needed you to greenlight it and then he
would write something he used to have
game I can get Ray Allen Ray's got time
you ready yeah
so what do you think right well I think
I gotta take the bull by the horns
because you know spike and I have had
this conversations over the last two or
three years and we've been saying the
same thing like we get this LM bored but
it's easier to get it yes if you have
that script that's in the process being
written and almost complete so we got to
just get the ball rolling is there a
script that's being written right now to
my knowledge no but you know we spike
and I have told over ideas talked about
certain scenarios and things that we
would certainly like to proceed forward
and talking about because right now and
sports is not only sports but in in the
world right now there's so many good
topics we've discussed that kind of
relate to sports so you know so much to
talk about did you have to audition for
that role I did and one of one of it I
think mr. sessions around
the the audition process not only for me
but for the other guys that audition was
that I was given the role where I was
guaranteed the role before our audition
for spike what he did was he he wanted
to know if he knew that all of us that
he was asking to audition for the movie
come who because he was going to the
basketball community but he wanted to
know who could act if anybody he didn't
want to have to have this generic
basketball film where he had to cut away
and you know show different you know
clips and edits just to make it look
like the guy could play basketball he's
a basketball fan he knew that he could
tap into the basket of basketball
community so when he asked him he said
would you be willing to commit and if
you don't get the main role that you're
reading for there's always other roles
that you possibly could get so I was
open I was like you know I never thought
it would amount to what it amounts to so
I'm just thankful that I had the
wherewithal as a 22 year old kid to say
yes and not worry about what I was doing
at the moment
who else was up for that role you know a
I was asked Marv bear was asked kg was
asked Colby was asked Felipe Lopez was
asked and then you know just I don't
know who else he has I know between
those guys you know everybody that came
in with me that year we were all like
put in position to audition and see if
we would be interested in doing it so
you know it was you know anybody that
was young at the time that could pull
off 18 year old kids yeah you know what
was interesting too there's the scene at
the end when denzel's character scores
on you was it in the script that he's
supposed to like Denzel played a little
bit of basketball JB basketball in
college at Fordham but Ray you're 22 at
the time I mean you know you're two-way
player you're great Denzel really score
on you well let me set it up for you Dan
here we go too far here we go I walk on
the set and I'm reading the script
it's about you know we shoot from from
darkness to light so we're in Coney
Island it's on the boardwalk you know
people are hanging on the side of the
court looking out from the balcony and
they're in the project and the script
had us you know it's probably 11 0 he
doesn't stand a chance because he's
trying to convince me to go to the
warrens alma mater so when we start I
don't know how this scene is gonna work
you know and you know I'm still new to
the whole acting game as it was anyway
so when we start then they'll have the
ball and I don't know if he's gonna go
at me or if he's gonna just kind of lay
down but this man there we had a slight
breeze it was coming off the ocean and
he shot the ball like one is shot and
I'm sitting there guarding and you know
you watching the scene and the ball
looks like it comes from the heavens and
then this backboard is a large steel
backboard it just hit like the corner of
the backboard it goes in and I was
thinking to myself okay spike cut that's
not supposed to happen and then then he
just takes on this persona but it's like
he becomes this person that is really
school of me and then the next shot he
takes he makes it and then everybody you
know I'm gonna come look out of corn my
I don't want to break you know character
but I'm thinking like us like you not
supposed to make any bad fight just left
to go because he believes organically
this is what's supposed to happen but
eventually you know he wears down and
then I kick in and then I start to
develop my confidence and I just take
over and the way the scene happened it
was so authentic you know that you know
there's a segment where we cut before we
start shooting more and I went over to
the sideline my acting coach she's
looking at me she's like what are you
doing I cannot believe that you let him
score you're supposed to be in the NBA
and she just like like
ridiculed me and I had to tell her I
said Susan you know basketball sometimes
it has a mind of its own I can't control
once the ball goes up what happened you
know it just he made the shot I could
control it and he just didn't understand
it because he thought I was this high
a player that he didn't stand a chance
when it came to me in basketball because
I didn't have chance when it came to him
but just acting so it was it was perfect
and then they'll prove to me then that
no matter what he can do what he was
doing or what role he was performing he
can become that person a hundred percent
he did that that's pretty moment but do
you think that he lobbied spike just to
put that shot in no I think that he you
know once you it's one thing to have
what you want you know from the script
to you know what you get on camera I
believe that because he watched the
dailies every every night that helped
with editing you know certain things but
I didn't believe that the scene was too
good that once spike saw what he had he
there was no way that he was not going
to put it in there because I think from
the viewership perspective you you have
to believe that I got it honest no I
thought it was authentic play yeah I
thought it was on it yeah a little bit
there and then you could just see where
you're like you know now I'm gonna
really school you now I'm gonna dominate
you after you make that shot you could
just see like your your competitiveness
kicked in in that scene where you didn't
have to act I think you were just being
Ray Allen yeah I mean there was a part
of me that was I felt like slighted a
little bit like I had to really show who
I was as a as a player at the NBA
players I hold on now I'm in my
territory I have to take over and prove
that I'm actually the guy that was
offered this role because I come from
the NBA community and I have to show
these people what I'm made of
he's Ray Allen the new book is from the
outside my journey through life and the
game I love available online and
wherever books are sold
there's so much to your career ray where
you're drafted Timberwolves traded to
the box for Steph Marbury the Seattle
situation you got to play for the
SuperSonics in that great city
everything that happened with the
Celtics and the big three and then the
falling out you go to Miami and win
another
idle there that's a hell of a journey
there ray yeah a lot it happens and so I
think prophetic for me to be in this
position now to sit back and say you
know I can write a book like sit back
and reflect on everything and the ups
and down the highs and lows I would say
that you know winning two championships
I you know to be able to write a book I
could tell people you know it's not
about winning the championships I didn't
win that those moments that I won where
I voices trophy or hit a shot but
winning was the journey winning was
everything that I went through when I
was on bad teams I didn't give up and I
continued to perfect my craft and you
know even when I dealt with adverse
situations with teammates or coaches you
know I had to figure it out I had to
find out like you know what do I need to
do to improve we used to always say when
you get traded you know if you're the
problem and you don't know it well the
next situation you move to that problem
still exists so you have to figure out
how to evolve how to grow how to how to
you know you know immerse yourself in a
new situation because as a young player
your journey is always continually being
crafted and your your evolution of the
player so that's kind of my whole career
I just kind of learned so much along the
way and that's why I wanted to write a
book because it's important that people
know that I didn't plan to NBA when I
was 10 years old you know I was still
learning I was learning how to get to
where I want to go on but when were you
the problem ray well I mean
interestingly enough I don't know I I
know that when I left Miami or when I
left Boston I started learning that I
was the problem in locker room and I
always thought that I was a good
teammate I always thought that I was
good and in every locker room now I was
in because I would do whatever it took
to help the team win what you find out
is you just don't do it on other
people's terms you don't do them do it
the way other people want you to do it
and you know for a long time you hear
other people opinions you know and I
know that people were upset with me and
they're disappointed because I left but
when you're not value
and when you're not happy that's when
you have to decide to move on and it's
unfortunate because that made me all the
sudden that's villain you know when you
also me go to seek your own happiness so
I don't ever feel like I was a problem
in any locker room I was in and I was
doing everything I could to help win but
the problem too sometimes is I was I've
always been a confident person so you
just do things how you need to do them
like I have a routine and I've had a
routine my whole career and nobody could
throw me off of because I knew what it
took for me to be successful so now when
you don't do things the way individual
wants you to do them our team once
you're doing the fight and all of me to
exist I have to kind of do the things
that I need to do if you want to you
want me to help you win but do you think
that you'll ever be on the same page
with with Rondo and kg and Paul Pierce
you do you think you ever have that
moment where you can talk it out and you
know or is this unrepairable I know I've
never I've never had an issue you know
with any of those guys like it was
always brought to my attention that
there was an issue you know Paul and I
have talked it talked it out we we had a
chance to sit down and in many chances
but the other two there is their issues
that they have with me I don't have any
issues with them like I'm once I moved
on it was like I was hoping that you
know hey we move on you know that
bygones be bygones like it's basketball
like we are what are we doing here we're
playing a game and you take things so
personal I just always wanted to win on
every level I played in my life and you
know there are certain things that
happen like when I lose a game or when I
win the game after the game I'm not mad
at the other team their job is to take
away what I'm trying to give and they're
trying to get everything that I have so
that's about competition the one thing
that we have to teach our kids is you go
to where the best exists you find out
what what they do when you learn from
them to become better but if they're not
great somewhere else like we don't
appreciate how great we can be because
they're the ones that take us to that
level so we should shake our opponents
hands there's no need to be
at or angry and so that's kind of where
I sit it's like I'm not it's not
personal ever but it feels like it is
for Rondo and cagey especially Rondo
well I mean I'll tell you with with
Rondo like you know the guys you know
when we first got together he was a
always a great kid you know always
looking for advice and asking questions
you know that's where we stood he was
like a little brother to us and that's
how it's always been and has never been
anything more so whatever they feel
whatever angst whatever like hang-ups
that they have against me like to me
it's not personal I don't have any
hatred towards them you know I'm I'm I'm
in a place where I'm so happy with my
life and people that are in it but for
them to hold any resentment anxiety you
win a championship in 2008 like maybe
that was all it was supposed to be for
us yeah we would have loved to have more
but what what do you what are you mad
about like what it what I don't
understand again they made it personal
yeah you're not making it personal it's
professional for you if I gave you a
hundred threes right now this afternoon
how many are you making if you gave me a
hundred yeah um I would probably make
I'll probably me 75 80 that's it I'll
tell you though I'll take those odds
what happened to young Rain Man
I mean no wonder you retired you only
given me 75 out of a hundred yeah all
day yeah what's the most ever
what's the most you ever hit in a row
like most threes in practice in practice
I mean for every shooter out there
people told me I said man I shoot a
thousand shot today you know I'm working
on my side and I want to be so
consistent I was like well you shoot a
thousand shots so you're a thousand man
shot I would much rather somebody shoot
a game a fourth-quarter playoff shot
every time and for me I could give you
20 of those shots
and make twenty in a row and I could
move on to the next segment of my
routine and that's pretty much all that
try the drill is that routine well Steph
Curry does that right Steph Steph
practices tough shots and that's what I
always tell people it's very rare when
you're gonna get like a 15-foot jumper
with nobody's hand in your face so
practice shots that are gonna come up
you know in real time so I think that's
that's you yeah if you watch if you
watch some guys in in the playoffs now
like you see guys are wide open they
miss wide-open shots because what
happens is you you rest or you relax and
then you don't go into that routine you
know where you're used to catching the
ball going quick and taking the shot and
you could you could figure out your
timing and get it up and make that shot
but then when you settle down and you
rest and you just take it easy shot you
miss because you don't jump the same you
know and so you know when you go to
shoot you have to find that rhythm that
you do the same way every single time
and you have to do it with the
assumption that somebody is gonna run
out to you have my opportunity block
your shot so I would rather kids
practice that routine and if you shot if
you got 200 of those shots a day I
guarantee you got you have one hell of a
workout in that particular moment as
opposed to just going in and Jim is
sitting there taking 300 or 400
standstill shots where you're really not
you know practicing for what might be a
tough shot in the fourth quarter well
you're preaching to the congregation
here I'm right there with you raise two
great shooters talking here and I
understand that you're saying there hey
good luck with the book I'd love to
check in with you you know when the
playoffs get a little deeper here and
you know tap into your expertise but the
book is from the outside my journey
through life and the game I love
available online wherever books are sold
rayray good to talk to you then always
good to talk to you it's over gear all
right round ten time NBA all-star for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
2:39 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]